on va avec Christian Dubé c'est le seul
que je vous confirme que je vous ai
confirmé Christian va travailler à
mettre en place son plan en santé on va
continuer aussi
de protéger promouvoir le français
alors c'est monsieur Legault aujourd'hui
alors mes invités on les a convié à
former un conseil des ministres alors on
va vous présenter des photos il y a des
gens qui sont déjà là il y a des gens
qui vont s'en aller puis dans les
recrues que lesquels ont choisi un gros
casse-tête vous pouvez me le dire au
passage tous les quatre alors je
commence avec les noms fournis par
Valérie dans les ministres possibles on
voit Geneviève Guilbaud Bernard
drinville Christian Dubé
on voit Jonathan Julien martine Biron
François Bonnardel et puis on voit votre
trio économique là
Eric Girard Sonia Lebel et Monsieur
fadigun alors commençons par parlons des
recrues d'abord là vous avez une
certitude que les recrues Bernard
drinville Martin Biron vont être du
Conseil des ministres ben on a
l'impression ils ont eu des très très
larges majorité ils ont c'est des
vedettes des journalistes qui sont
passés du côté de la CAQ monsieur de
rêver de l'expérience on peut présumer
qui est peut-être pas retourné là pour
rester sur les bancs la banquette
arrière et
j'avais envie de le mettre aussi dans ma
liste parce que cet après-midi il y a
une mère de les vigilolier on sait à
quel point le troisième bien est
important et il y a une mère de Lévy qui
a dit il faudrait bien ministre sur la
rive sud de Québec on est dû on avait le
président de l'Assemblée nationale
François Paradis mais là ce serait bien
et il a évoqué pourquoi pas monsieur
Drainville ministre des Transports alors
c'est un clin d'œil aussi au fait que
Monsieur draguer de pas manquer une
occasion d'aller défendre vertement le
projet de troisième lien rappelons-nous
sa déclaration là chez nous avec les GS
alors il a vraiment même dans des
contextes où l'annonce ne portait pas
sur le troisième bien il a été à l'avant
et en tout cas cette déclaration là ne
serait de le qualifierait pas
nécessairement pour l'environnement par
contre mais on peut penser que Monsieur
draguer ne sera pas suffisant et
voyez-vous martine Biron ben martine
Biron je sais pas peut-être parce que
c'est la proximité avec je parle avec
des collègues puis des gens qui disent
est-ce qu'elles n'est pas par ça sa
connaissance des enjeux comme ex
journaliste un rôle de présidente
peut-être de l'Assemblée nationale je
sais pas mais moi j'évoquais peut-être
c'est peut-être un peu traditionnel ça a
été le cas de Nathalie Roy qui peut être
ce restaurant mais culture communication
on peut imaginer qu'elle serait qualifié
pour ses enfants alors pensez à
quelqu'un que vous allez enlever du
Conseil des ministres quand je vais
avoir fini ma tournée moi je me suis
laissé directement pour aller à
l'enseignement supérieur alors Guillaume
vos choix on va les montrer vous aussi
martine Biron et vous vous avez donné 9
choix c'est neuf femmes neuf nouvelles
femmes on va les montrer en régie
martine Biron Cateri champagne-jourdain
avec conversation attente Sonia Bélanger
l'ancienne président du 6 dans le coin
de Montréal Karine boisvertois qu'on a
connu dans l'hémunicipalité chirurgie
dorismond aussi à millidion Céline a
italiane Christine Frechette qu'on a
connu aussi
me faire un conseil des ministres à la
Bernard Landry
en fait je les mettais de l'avant parce
que je sais qu'elles sont dans les
réflexions c'est ce qu'on nous dit je
pense pas que toutes ces nouvelles
recrues vont être là mais elle compte
quand même et le défi à l'heure actuelle
au cabinet de Monsieur Lego évidemment
tous les ministres ont été élus ça c'est
pas une première ça doit être pas être
loin de ça là c'est quand même très rare
et on a quand même la joue d'environ 27
recrues dont plusieurs femmes
effectivement avec des parcours
intéressants qui pourraient aider à
amener
absolument puisqu'on disait aussi je
trouve intéressant parce que le goût la
manière dont il fait la réflexion ça
peut nous guider un peu dans l'analyse
de ça c'est pas tellement de voir quelle
est l'expertise précise d'une personne
pour le ministère plutôt que d'avoir des
qualités générales par exemple de
communication de gestion d'être capable
de porter certains changements alors ça
peut faire en sorte qu'on sera surpris
peut-être de la signation de certains
certaines personnes au moment de faire
le Conseil des ministres mais dans le
lot de ces recrues là certainement que
qu'on
oui notamment madame Bélanger oui qui
donc était PDG ducius du droit
intéressant pour Monsieur Dubé oui et
notamment et ça c'est peut-être
l'exception ce que je viens de vous dire
c'est à dire que elle son expertise est
très très forte dans un domaine ou quand
même il y a un certain besoin en ce
sens-là qui est Madame le poste de
Madame Marguerite Blaye est disponible
puisqu'il ne s'est pas représenté aux
gens que vous allez retirer du Conseil
des ministres dans quelques minutes
Geneviève je vais avec vos propositions
dans les ministres possibles la première
photo qu'on va voir sont des gens qui
sont déjà là bien installés d'Eric
Girard Christian Dubé Geneviève Guilbaud
simonge Alain barrette sonnait level qui
peuvent dormir tranquille même s'ils ont
pas si ils vont attendre comme tout le
monde le coup de fil de monsieur Legault
dans les autres ministres possibles
c'est encore des gens qui sont là
Chantal Roulot il y a une Lafrenière
Lionel karma Benoît Charette
ensuite là il y a des recrues ici là
alors intéressant nous au recrues
Suzanne Tremblay Bernard Drainville
Martin Biron Cateri
champagne-jourdain et je suis allée de
rizmo pensez-vous qu'il y en a trois
dans celle-là qui sont incontournables
je vais parler de Suzanne Tremblay parce
que les autres on en a discuté alors
bien connu dans la région c'est elle qui
a pris la circonscription dehors et donc
la question qu'on se pose ici dans la
région c'est est-ce que l'outaway aurait
deux ministres j'exclut pas du tout
Mathieu Lacombe non plus alors ça
pourrait rendre l'exercice intéressant
mais moi ce que je me suis la chose à
laquelle je me suis intéressé c'était la
parité parce que monsieur Legault c'est
mémoire est bonne en fait mention c'est
peut-être pas une promesse mais je pense
qu'il y avait mentionner un moment donné
qui aimerait bien avoir un cabinet
paritaire en ce moment il y a 26
ministres si on exclut monsieur Legault
ça voudrait dire 13 hommes 13 femmes il
y a trois femmes qui sont quitté le
cabinet parce qu'elle ne se sont pas
représentées ce qui laisse la place à
des nouvelles femmes pour parvenir au
cabinet mais c'est quand même elles ne
sont que 11 en ce moment alors dernier
cabinet 11 comparativement à 15 hommes
si on voulait la parité il faudrait que
ça soit très stress donc il y aura des
hommes actuellement qui perdrait leur
poste et donc
oui ou non je vais vous donner une autre
solution on augmente la taille du
cabinet pour le rendre à 15 à 30 je veux
dire et donc on est en train de 15
hommes 15 ans et je pense que monsieur
Legault est relativement fidèle
vis-à-vis c'est trop puis on n'a pas vu
beaucoup de remaniement ministériels au
cours de son mandat et je pense qu'on va
voir pas mal les mêmes figures je
m'attends en plus de femmes donc parmi
les personnes je vous ai mentionné ça me
surprendrait pas mais il y a Bernard
brinsville qui à mon avis est un
incontournable qui va s'ajouter au
cabinet
Michel vous nous avez envoyé les
ministres possibles mais dans on va les
revoir Sonia le Bel soit stressable
Bernard drinville martine Biron qui
atterrit champagne-jourdain donc vous
quatre vous ramener en tout cas Bernard
drinville Martin Biron et 4 rue
champagne-jourdain oui je pense que
Madame champagne Jourdain
ne serait-ce que passer c'est une femme
c'est ce serait la première autochtone
je vous conseille de mais je pense que
c'est incontournable je doute beaucoup
que ça soit aux relations avec les
autochtones à la placerait dans une
situation extrêmement confus d'intérêt
puis ça serait vraiment toujours entre
l'arbre et l'écorce mais je l'avais très
bien par exemple au développement
économique régional je pense que ça va
être impliqué dans des projets d'éoliens
puis de oui mais vous voulez
l'environnement de séparer ça du
développement durable je comprends qu'on
peut augmenter le nombre de ministères
mais il y a des limites il y a oui il y
a des gens qui qui sont des
incontournables mais qui sont pas
nécessairement collés sur leur siège on
comprend que Monsieur Girard monsieur
filsgainville changeront pas
d'affectation mais madame Lebel par
exemple
elle a pas une formation économique qui
est pas automatique qui soit au Conseil
du Trésor elle est très polyvalente pour
aller un peu n'importe où il y a
monsieur Legault avait évoqué pendant la
campagne la possibilité de n'avoir plus
un duo à la santé mais un trio à la
santé alors je pense que Madame
dorismond
c'est bien passé syndicaliste il y a
beaucoup de à rebâtir avec avec les
infirmières je pense que ça serait une
excellente prospect et moi aussi je
pense que madame Tremblay dans dans
quelqu’un et je pense pas que Monsieur
monsieur Lacombe soit un candidat à une
éviction il va il va demeurer ministre
mais je pense qu'il pourrait y avoir
deux
majorité aussi là dans le coin c'est pas
mal rapidement alors qui ne devrait
partir c'est difficile ce que je vous
demande et c'est presque cruel en fait
c'est parce que monsieur Legault va
devoir
vous devez simuler la difficulté que
Monsieur Lego va avoir de dire merci
bonsoir à quelques personnes il y en a
je vais continuer un peu la question
parce que sans les éjecter complètement
du Conseil des ministres mais c'est sûr
que Jean-François Roberge à l'éducation
ne peut plus être là c'est une évidence
pas nécessairement parce qu'il a
tellement démérités mais les relations
avec le milieu ne sont pas bonnes même
réflexion pour Nathalie Roy à la culture
qui a quand même réussi à en toute fin
de mandat à faire cette révision des
lois sur le statut de l'artiste et les
relations avec le milieu ont été
extrêmement difficiles au fil du temps
donc il y a des gens comme ça qui sent
peut-être à être complètement et Vinci
doivent néanmoins changer de chaîne
on a vu que c'était l'immigration
peut-être il sera très intéressant de
suivre est-ce qu'il y aura un
par rapport au travail ou d'autres
ministères façon de montrer la confiance
tout encore évidemment dans le 27 ans je
suis le seul que vous évincez moi j'ai
un sort un peu certains pour Jonathan
Julien vous allez dire que j'en ai que
pour Bernard drinville mais c'est un
nouvel élu de la région il a été à
l'époque du gouvernement Pékin
porte-parole en matière de l'énergie
ressources naturelles est-ce que ça
pourrait être un prospect Geneviève qui
vous est Vinci j'en ai 20 fois je vous
l'ai dit tantôt j'augmente mon conseil
des ministres la question bon par contre
je doute que Monsieur Robert je reste à
son poste monsieur boulet faudrait
attention parce que il a quand même été
un excellent ministre il a fait une
gaffe monumentale en campagne électorale
c'est quand même quelqu'un
oui mais je reste pas l'immigration mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a livré la
marchandise pour Monsieur le goût donc
je le vois pas être invinci du cabinet
il faut un évincer Michel il y a des
considérations régionales qui font des
déceptions aussi peut-être 90 le poste
de certains mais par exemple moi Pierre
Dufour à la forêt là je pense pas que ça
soit quelqu'un qui est indispensable
disons ça comme ça dans un cabinet et
toute sa gestion le caribou ça a été
pénible du début à la fin son mandat
alors moi je trouve ça serait un bon
candidat à l'éviction madame Roy
nettement bon je comprends que la loi
sur le statut de l'artiste mais pense
pas qu'elle a été transcendante pendant
son mandat et je comprends que c'est une
femme mais il y a beaucoup de candidates
qui ont été élus et qui pourraient très
bien je pense prendre les
bah monsieur Ker aussi honnêtement
monsieur care ça a pas été un grand
grand succès
[Musique]
alors
échappé par sablement parce que lui il
était délégué à alors c'est cette façon
mais
il va quand même falloir garder puis je
pense à Monsieur badardel par exemple je
pense que monsieur Legault doit garder
dans son cabinet des anciens de la décu
parce que il y a quand même le Parti
conservateur qui s'ouvre dans le dos il
va falloir qu'il garde des gens
auxquels ces électeurs-là peuvent
s'identifier puis j'allais dire un poste
qui va être intéressant ministre
responsable de la métropole considérant
le le manque d'assise de la CAQ et la
performance de Chantal rouleau a pas été
très bien très bien évalué au cabinet
donc ce sera survé va se garder le poste
parce que beaucoup parler moi je suis de
Montréal mais il est pas député à
Montréal monsieur
mais il y a un bureau à Montréal une
résidence
ça très bien merci d'avoir fait
l'exercice pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI